like um well first before i get into i
also want to talk about the cultural
impact of this yeah because uh
the north korean girl is ted yuck you
see her instagram following dude she's
huge it's like 13 million now holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] well first of all i heard
she's like this is her first time acting
first time acting too wow knocked it out
the park oh [ __ ] bro yeah this is what
i'm talking about right when we talk
about the level of acting this is why
sometimes i feel that
when people say we always try to give
like certain in five four three two one
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast hold
on i need to get my glass of vino
you forgot that yeah
there we go cheers cheers
there is no genius brain without a
little bit of
alcohol my friends it's a little poison
in your veins have you been have you
been following do you follow ariel
helwani
a little like just when he comes up on
the news i'm like what did this guy say
what did the nose say you know him and
brendan schaab are beefing what why so i
guess
like i don't follow
too much of
like errol helwani i don't follow him
too but not because i don't like him i
just see him on everything so i don't
need to follow him because he's going to
be on every single mma outlet anyways
right i don't follow him because he used
to be on espn all the time but now that
he left i actually haven't been once
known i haven't known what he's been up
to he's assigned to a bunch of different
companies because he's not married to
espn anymore right so he's just a
contract yeah i think he's a part of
like vox media now he's doing really
well like he's a huge name in in sports
in general specifically mixed martial
arts right
but i guess on a podcast
um brendan schaub said something about
he said that people don't like working
with
ariel helwani because he's difficult to
work with yeah and he said i heard from
a few other people that work with him
that it sucks to work with him or
whatever which i didn't think that it
would be something that aaron helwani
would get really mad at
but you know i think he always plays the
heel so
people always [ __ ] on him or whatever
but now that he's not a part of espn he
doesn't really have a code of conduct
that's really anchoring him down yeah
he's going off he's like [ __ ] brendan's
job like [ __ ] you like you don't know
[ __ ] about me he starts going after his
stand up saying like he's like oh how's
your [ __ ] career going don't you have
like a 1.7 on on imdb for your stamina
[ __ ] likes he goes he goes and anybody
who [ __ ] with brendan shop brian kellen
[ __ ] you uh [ __ ] what
you're your [ __ ] podcast producer
[ __ ] you all your little lackeys that
you're he's like tupac now yeah
yeah he's going off dude and he's like
calling brenda's shop on on his uh
on his show
on the what i think it's called like the
nose or something like that yeah he's
calling brendan shop on his podcast
saying oh you think i'm scared of you he
goes i'm not scared of you at all i'll
call you right now he starts calling him
on his podcast waiting for his response
so he says that the only way he'll stop
[ __ ] with brendan shop is if he uh
publicly gives him an apology
what the [ __ ] what
that's um that's some [ __ ] balls i
know i would be so scared to say
anything like that like but he but
that's what he's known for right that's
why he knows he annoys a lot of fighters
because he's like pretty brash with his
questions
so like
it's pretty amazing the kind of
confidence this guy walks around with
dude a hundred percent man because he's
not scared of anybody
i'm not saying that obviously he's not
going to beat up anybody i mean he's
going to get his [ __ ] ass beat by
everybody yeah nice guy scrawny dude
but in terms of him as a journalist and
what he's going to say and what he's
going to do
he backs it up 24 [ __ ] seven yeah
that's true he gets all the info like
he's always right about [ __ ] he'll
[ __ ] ask uncomfortable questions 24
7. but yeah he's going out to brenda's
shop like stand up talking about um he's
like oh
you keep selling you you keep telling us
that you're selling out shows but it's
funny because i see your shows on
groupons because you can't sell it at
full price so is that how you're selling
your full shows i'm like bro this guy's
[ __ ] crazy wants all that heat i
wonder i wonder why he took that so
offensively though
what what exactly did brandon shop say
he talked about his uh professionalism
in a work sense how people don't like to
work with him and that was the thing
that tipped it over and he just pissed
as [ __ ] about it and i'm like that's the
thing that makes you mad i mean doesn't
he work as a journalist do you usually
work alone
i mean he has he got i mean he's working
for multiple companies so clearly it's
not true right yeah so i don't i don't
know maybe it's because he went personal
about him as as a character
as a person right yeah
yeah and i guess and if props to him if
he's going after
everything but brendan's character
it's just like hmm and he's like saying
brian caland he's like you better watch
out because i know [ __ ] about you too so
he's he's really putting it out there i
can't believe he called him up on his
podcast and he's not picking up
but then on the fighter and the kid i
saw i just saw a clip today where
he's saying you know yo like i respect
ariel hawaiian blah blah and i think i
[ __ ] up like i you know i overstepped
my boundaries i even texted him like i
apologize he goes i don't want to text
you said that you were going to give me
a public [ __ ] apology [ __ ] your text
give me my public apology
crazy that's a weird like power balance
yeah like for a [ __ ] giant guy like
him he's just like a calm
[ __ ] ariel
like he's like six feet tall like 160
pounds yeah you know brendan shop's 250
jacked yoked as [ __ ]
kind of a weird thing dude
but
what we're going to talk about today is
the long
[ __ ] harassing me about
so we actually did a squid game review
but i think i drank a little too much
yeah
our first recording uh
i looked back on it i was like you know
i do pat ourselves on the back because i
was like damn we have pretty good memory
yeah we went over the entire [ __ ]
season yeah
episode perhaps straight from our memory
but
like what was we were just recapping
here i was listening to it again because
i was a little buzzed you know and then
you know the next day i was kind of
skimming through it i'm like we didn't
really talk about it we were just kind
of relishing how dope every episode was
you know this is the worst squid game
podcast breakdown ever dude yeah we're
just like spoiling it for people who
haven't seen it and it was a little too
early for that yeah that time too
i i think i'm so shocked yeah at
how much of uh of a cinematic phenomena
this is right right the cultural
phenomenon yeah it is
hitting like every nation that has
netflix yeah and maybe the ones that
don't like i know in iraq
if you go to i just remember about the
bazaar there's just like tens of
thousands of dvds all bootlegs it's like
so you can watch anything out there but
anyways just to say like how big this
show has gotten culturally
like wow this is uh this is somewhat
bigger than parasite
yeah i mean this the most watched series
in netflix history
i think the number was like
111 million individual accounts have
watched it that's crazy which says
that's that's not accounting for the
other millions of accounts that haven't
seen it they get a billion dollars a
month from subscriptions
that's crazy dude so that's why i wanna
say like for season two this
[ __ ] better get all the
resources yeah yeah like he's gotta get
everything going on i mean
i guess for me like when i when i
thought about it right like i
squid games is so dope yeah you know as
for me as expected for a lot of korean
shows right
i wonder what made this one hit so hard
i'm very curious as to why people
connected with this one so much and
there's a lot of comparisons to
uh battle royale yeah uh
alice in borderland yeah which i tried
getting into i couldn't get into it um
so like for my
theory i guess when i was looking at it
was that
um like battle royale border uh alice in
borderlands um all this genre does come
out of japan right yeah um like
and you can even put hunger games into
into this genre right
the underlying thing that they all have
in common is that it's not voluntary
right and the games don't really they
might be an allegory to something but
i've never really cared yeah right also
being it's it's a little too far-fetched
and it's usually in a dystopian society
a dystopian future or whatever right but
squid game says like
yo this could happen now you know what
it's like you know like this is
we live in this kind of society today
that's the thing about squid game it's
like what would it ask
every viewer like what would you do
would you play the game do you want this
money that kind of thing i think that's
why especially in westernized countries
like that's why it's so wild to see
white people love this [ __ ] yeah you
know more than parasite the the yeah
that's true i didn't really think about
that because in battle royale they
didn't have a choice they didn't have a
choice right this one they have a choice
and in fact in squid game they had a
choice to leave they left and a majority
of them still decided to come back big
part of the plot
it's a big part of the philosophy behind
the entire game is that
you ask for this
you want this right it's about desire
like um well first before i get into i
also want to talk about the cultural
impact of this yeah because uh
the north korean girl is happy
you see her instagram following dude
she's huge it's like 13 million now holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] well first of all i heard
she's like this is her first act first
time acting too wow knocked it out the
park oh [ __ ] bro yeah this is what i'm
talking about right when we talk about
the level of acting this is why
sometimes i feel that
when people say we always try to give
like certain agents slack i was like oh
this is their first big feature film
whatever hey her first time acting
period yeah
all right i don't want to hear [ __ ]
we better see a ghost in the shell
reboot
bro her and ghost in the shell would be
[ __ ] amazing well like the way i'm
seeing it though because of like
like
like chiang chi right and i hate to
bring it up again but it's very chinese
yeah right and i think if they make
ghosts and they'll it goes in a shell
again it'd have to be very
japanese not like how multicultural it
was well we'll just do a 23andme i bet
she has a little bit of japanese in here
that she'll be fine dude so even in
squid game if there was a remake you
know who i kept thinking about as the
lead as kyun
[ __ ] john cho
oh that'd be really have you seen john
cho right now because he's about to do
the live-action cowboy bebop
so he's got the long hair and everything
oh [ __ ] he [ __ ] looks like cuban oh
does he yeah
that's hilarious
but we both also agreed there shouldn't
be a remake yeah i mean this is what i
was like i always get worried when
something korean pops off big i'm like
okay is this gonna be another my sassy
girl american version old boy american
version again just don't touch it but
that's
that's precisely the reason why you
can't remake a show like this or
um like parasite like
for me
when i saw parasite win the oscar for
best picture like uh huge for for us and
our culture our people and like our
impact
around the world or whatever right
um
but
it was a movie that can't be made as an
american movie yeah you know because
it's a movie about classism right
but you can't talk about american
classism without talking about race
right yeah so you know the poor family
can't be like this white family trying
to scam this other white family kind of
thing it's
it's too unrelatable for us as americans
but as americans we can see a
homogenized country of all koreans and
look at class without race yeah right
and understand where we are in that
picture
right it's because if you if you had a
movie like parasite in america you'd
have to have it has to be about race
it's intertwined poverty and race yeah
in this country so it's like when we
as koreans right or people around the
world they watch american films about
american culture
we're watching white and black people
struggle to live together
right
um and it's because of race right with a
little hint of class
um
but when the whole world saw parasite
they saw classism for what it is
you know because they didn't have to
think about the race yeah you know and
that's just what the beauty of
a movie winning the oscar talking about
what's happening
in our culture and our times today
you know like the americans can really
understand the society we live in with
the system that you see going on from
living in the basement to living on the
top of the hill yeah yeah marielle and i
talked about it in our podcast where we
watched the
this this little docu-series on youtube
and once again i'm forgetting the name
but they were talking about the high
suicide rates in in korea like first of
all like suicide rates in korea outbeats
everybody as a country like in your
[ __ ] face
also number one porn consumers i i
learned about that oh for real yeah
what the [ __ ] are we killing ourselves
so much
big time alcohol consumers big time
cigarette consumers across
it has to do and that's all stress
induced stuff you know and then um i was
mention i mentioned this before too but
there was a kid that was being
interviewed and they were asked like oh
what are your dreams he goes i don't
have dreams i have goals
never even thought about what his dreams
are you know going to you know the top
three or three major universities in
korea is a goal to have yeah and when we
put this idea of what your goals are you
don't know what it is and we always have
this reoccurring theme where we talk
about class in korean it's
you know we always mention it in
churches yeah like classism is super
high in churches yeah what you say what
you do how you behave is a reflection of
who you are and if you say something out
of turn that gossip is going to go
around it makes you look bad and that's
why you can't buy the toyota and go to
church you have to buy the lexus
exactly
you don't get a bmw sometimes the
mercedes is way better yeah you know and
this is something that happens too like
even in the nuclear korean family right
there are times where public perception
is put before the happiness of their own
children i've heard this so many times
with a lot of korean american kids right
they go oh my parents told me not to do
this because of how it would make them
look or our family look rather than say
does this make you happy is what you're
doing making you happy but instead it's
how is it going to make me look like to
all these church people
oh gosh
yeah i mean my mom called me about squid
game right because she was really hyped
about how popular it is and like hello
my friends let's keep this podcast going
and sponsored by our lovely sponsor
current my friends if you are sick of
the current baking system not this
current that you have with all their
stupid fees long lines and clunky ass
apps then currents will be the one for
you i'm right there with you technology
is improving at a very fast rate and i
got to tell you something i want my
banking to be as easy streamline and
advanced as everything else because why
the hell not it's all about
accessibility and why should we always
get surprised by weird fees when all i
want is that flexibility freedom and
faster access to our [ __ ] money
current is a tech company and lets you
manage your money on your phone that's
how it should be affordable no surprises
and no minimum balance since that's how
it should be
my friend i love it remember my friends
it's your last chance to be a part of
our current giveaway we've partnered
with current to give away 500 to our
listeners current is going to give away
a hundred dollars to five listeners of
our show all you have to do is download
the current app and enter our code brain
during sign up for a chance to win
that's brain during sign up the giveaway
closes
soon on october 20th 2021
so sign up now before it's too late
download the current app sign up in less
than two minutes and enter code brain
for a chance to win visit current.com
brain for full terms and conditions uh
telling me ideas about what stevie
should make like based off of squid game
faint food or whatever make a sweet dish
[Laughter]
all this stuff so i was like oh what'd
you think about the show she's like oh i
didn't see it
what the [ __ ] because she's a christian
oh yeah i wish she can't go to church
and talk about oh squid gang did you see
it yeah you're like oh no you sinner
yeah you want to go to hell i guess she
saw the first episode and once they
started like [ __ ] mowing down
everybody at the red light turn it off
she turned it off but it's such a that's
interesting though because it's such a
good ref not a good but
we always talk about too how a lot of
these korean films is based on classism
yes it's one of the biggest issues that
we have in career right or
i i would say it's a lot of stuff that
kind of
people know about it bothers them but
they don't really speak up against it
tell me about a korean movie where the
rich wealthy man is the good guy
never never right if you watch any
modern korean movie rich people are the
bad people
yeah they're always doing something evil
behind the scenes the only rich good guy
you'll see is if they make a biopic
about some old you know chosen king
you know
that's true
you know if if i could give somebody
like a little bit of insight if they say
well i can't really relate to that
because obviously classism is different
here it's very much tied to race like
you were saying
something small i think about how the
reason why we buy things right
specifically in big metropolitan cities
yeah we tend to buy things that are a
little more flashy a little more
expensive with bigger brand names
because we want to show that we're cool
and we belong that's a level of classes
of itself right it's like when you buy a
kanye west t-shirt right he'll he'll
sell a cotton ring spun white t-shirt if
you walked outside and you didn't tell
me that was a kanye west t-shirt i was
like nice target t-shirt [ __ ]
that's it but then you walk out and you
go hey man i just caught the [ __ ] from
[ __ ] kanye's new line i would have
never known yeah it's the idea that
sometimes we buy things to show people
that we're better than them and i i i
feel that sometimes too yeah you better
not get caught wearing [ __ ] skull ear
buds right
oh my god skull would you buy that
walmart did you get that at the airport
because you [ __ ] lost your earbuds
checkout lane that's like safeway or
something you know
it's it's all this stuff too right but
there's a lot of companies who are now
fighting against it like like stop
paying for premium [ __ ] when you could
just get the same ship for a lower price
but a lot of that stuff sometimes a lot
of that stuff at times has to do with
class you want to be a part of an elite
group you want to be a part of the cool
group like i don't know how many times i
bought a shoe i walked out they're like
fresh kicks i'm like
cool you know for me my my and i used to
do that a lot too and i'm kind of like
speaking to myself like when i bought
these shoes was because it was tied to
how it made me feel when i was a kid
when i used to see other people with
shoes that i couldn't have yeah so we
have a a small window into that as well
it's maybe not as culturally tied but
you see that in a lot of metropolitan
cities and that's bringing back the
overarching theme
of uh squid game
see last time i thought it was an
allegory capitalism which it is the
games are very much an allegory to
capitalism but
um
the
real theory like because this this
happens in episode two so we i watched
it twice
you watched it again yeah through right
um
uh the cop guy i can't believe i don't
remember his name but um he goes into
ibyanghan's apartment that he's been
missing from right and he checks it out
the fish are dead and whatever there's a
book that he goes over and actually
shows up in the subtitles right the
theory of desire by jacques
uh
[ __ ] i forgot his last name
but
um i was so curious about that and then
so i crammed this week like reading
looking it up and all these philosophers
are talking about it apparently it's the
most complicated theory
like to explain
but in my like just couple hours of
watching youtube videos it's about
pretty much
um
you know
we are
like individual people right when we're
babies and we first see ourselves in the
mirror and recognize that it's us
ourselves that's when the ego is born
that's when you become subject right and
everything else is an object of
your wants and desires and then there's
a split between what a want is and what
a desire is
but the idea is that
um when you're a baby like mommy's
everything right but
when mama leaves because she needs to
eat some [ __ ] food take a [ __ ] you
know go see daddy or whatever
um babies get upset like where's mommy
where's mommy right but you see mom
hanging out with uh dad then as a child
you're like what does dad have that i
don't right and the theory is that
that's where it's born
to
have a desire in front of you to be like
something to have something um to to
need something in order to get that love
from our mothers
right but even once you grow out of the
adolescent stage where it's not about
mom and dad anymore
we still grow up into identifying
ourselves by the things we desire
right and the things we get and the
things by objects
right so let's say like you were saying
the way you talk about your tesla you
got it
now what
yeah you got a tesla yeah okay
right that it's not enough we have this
huge
it could be a
like a philosophy about consumerist
capitalism or whatever but
we are always left empty right once we
get that object this okay so i got that
girl
now what you better maintain that [ __ ]
right yeah oh i got that job now what
well you better grind nine to five for
the rest of your life
it's always gonna leave you
kind of like
left wanting more desiring more because
that object is just a dangling carrot on
a string yeah right in front of you
so like that's what actually squid game
like actually comes to be about towards
the end of the season because that's
what illinois the old man talks about
right yeah rich people poor people what
they have in common exactly
this this theory of desire right that's
and you know that's also a good
reflection upon the main character
one i mean look at him for example right
the biggest piece of [ __ ] ever yeah this
is the first there
squid game is one of those series two
there's no hero
the guy that's supposed to be the hero
in this story is consistently a piece of
[ __ ] yeah and if you know some people
may not see this or they might agree but
you have to understand if you look at
this guy's character right so there was
a clip of lebron james talking about
squid game really yeah so he watched
school game he's like hey i don't i
don't really like the ending a squid
game and they go why like that dude just
up and left his daughter like i don't
like how it ended i'm like but that is
true to his character that is who he is
if you look at it from beginning to end
you're always getting pulled apart right
you're like oh he shows these glimpses
of great humanity he chooses to save the
older man iran right he's going to save
him he's going to put him in his team
and then you see this glimpse of his
true character it's it's kind of even
his good deeds seems to be out of
selfish motive right it's because he
doesn't want to feel guilt it's not
because it's the right thing to do i
feel like he doesn't want to live with
that guilt so
one of the greatest things too is like i
think
really
showed who he is as a person is when it
was a scene that made me cry the [ __ ]
most because when they were playing the
marble game yeah of course yeah dude
episode six this is the sad gambu right
yeah the most saddest episode of tv like
since i don't know like i don't know
when the last of something on game of
thrones would like red wedding type of
[ __ ] dude he's like we're friends you're
you're my kang boo it's like a nickname
that you give your best friends as kids
right you're my kang boo and you hear
this
and you it kind of fortifies like the
strong bond that they've developed
throughout playing all these games
surviving helping each other out but
when it comes to that point where he has
to choose his life over his he doesn't
think about a solution where they can
both live he only thinks about himself
yeah and
you know you might say well you could
see that he was struggling with the idea
of taking those marbles however
his damning
the place where he was damned the most
is when he looks at him he goes hey at
the end he goes how about we just play
one last game
for all the marbles and what does he say
to him because why the [ __ ]
doesn't make any sense yeah right it was
like doesn't make any sense to trick me
and take all my marbles like
and it's the way that he reacted when he
when he made that proposal that makes
that shows his true character he looks
at him as if he has the moral high
ground yeah why the [ __ ] would that make
what are you talking about this is
insane why the [ __ ] would i give you all
my marbles and it's like wait hold on a
second
how did you talk to him as if he's
beneath you a misguided righteousness
yes so um that's one of the themes
oh man we just can't help ourselves
anyway yeah but um yeah for all the
people who keep saying that they hate
the ending
i propose that you watch the [ __ ]
show over again
and look at the character of what he's
like right um
first instance i believe we see
could be one of the first like um he
keeps losing the game of thakchi right
to kong right yeah um
and
so
instead of owing him a hundred bucks
congruent offers to slap him instead of
giving me you know 100 bucks so he keeps
getting [ __ ] slapped right but when
he finally wins
instead of
taking the money he originally [ __ ]
played it for he goes to slap him back
misguided righteousness
right it's like the self-righteousness
like it's the right thing to do or
whatever
um when he was at his ex-wife's
apartment and they're having an argument
and she was like you didn't even come to
your daughter's birth yeah he's like
my co-worker passed out you know
and like because he he's like trying to
say he was doing something righteous he
used to do this like
i was passed out your daughter was being
born yeah you know
like
um
then it goes to
even when um
even when he receives the money right
from his uh ex-wife's new husband yeah
he's like here's the money
to
uh
pay for your mom's medical bills
and he's like but in return don't come
to see us again he [ __ ] sucks him and
throws the money at him he's like yo
that's what you needed right there right
instead
yeah [ __ ] knocks him out right and
his daughter watching him in the rain in
the rain
koreans get this [ __ ] melodrama yeah
and then um
the other part
when
sangmu kills hepbuck
right
and in the next episode they're at the
the yard playing squid game
and he explains why
he's like you
would have gotten her to vote the games
to be over
i can't have that i have to win that
money
right he's like i know that you and your
self-righteousness would have ended this
whole thing what the [ __ ] have you been
doing this whole time yeah you would
have done some [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] like
that
then what happens
he beats up sangwoo he's right there to
win the game
and goes back to try to save someone's
life and go back and do exactly what
zhang said he was going to do to vote to
end the game yeah he's one last
and he stabs himself in the neck yeah
right
because it's just like he can't have
that that that's part of the things
about uh the difference between
need and want
xango needed to win the game right like
we as we saw his character he needed to
win
like kiewen he had the money in front of
him let's type it away
he found other options that's why he's
playing the game he wants to win the
game and it's showing the difference
between someone who wants to win because
that's it becomes conditional and
someone who needs someone who needs
absolutely needs to win
because and that's so [ __ ] true
because i don't even think about it like
that because when i look at his
situation that he has with his mom who
needs help with hospital bills there are
other options yeah there are there are
actually plenty of other options for him
the option for him is to not be a piece
of [ __ ] yeah you know conversely with
his situation he owes a [ __ ] ton of
people money like the government is
after him he needs to pay this debt back
if not he's [ __ ] his his mom's
business is in collateral her home it's
part of the collateral his thing is he
goes back he begs he gets the money he
could save his mom
and he chooses not to do it and i think
for a lot of people too you know i saw
people kind of
talking about his
basically saying that he's a he's a
decent person he goes well what would
you do if they tell you never to see
your kid i was like those ultimatums are
just
semi-conditional he could have taken it
and then not listen to it and saved his
mom because that should have been
priority
it's it's still stupid because if you
look at the n2 he goes oh well he wants
to save both their lives as friends dude
400 people died yeah
400 [ __ ] 154 at that point yeah yeah
at that point somebody has to win take
that money and try to do your best that
you can with it
i know it's obviously i'm not in this
[ __ ] squid game but we're just kind
of talking about what's true to his
character as a person before we continue
my friends thank you for listening to
our sponsored ads because raycon earbuds
is what we are sponsored by and i have
been sponsored by them for a long time
because i [ __ ] with them heavy premium
audio specifically from my work earbuds
that i just caught when i say you need
wireless earbuds with active noise
canceling i am for serious because for
example for me this past weekend i went
to hawaii for some work stuff and on the
plane i hate hearing the sound of jet
noises the engine people's chit chatter
if you turn on the active noise
canceling it cuts out a whole bunch of
that noise so all you have to do is sit
there chill and listen to whatever
you're listening on your earbuds with
that great premium audio and on top of
that did i tell you both a 32 hour
battery life yeah 32 hours that means
you don't have to worry about your
wireless earbuds dying on the plane
which has happened to me so many times
when i wasn't using my raycon work
earbuds and all i had was my stupid
other ones that failed me miserably and
i had to sit there on the plane for
hours doing absolutely nothing and by
the way if you're not happy 45-day free
return policy that's how confident they
are right now go to buy recon dot com
slash brain work to get 15 off your
recon order that's by buy
raycon
dot com slash brain work for 15 off
raycons today by raycon.com
brainwork
you know at the end what does he [ __ ]
do
calls his daughter daddy's coming home
gets a call hey i'm coming after you
leaves the [ __ ] plane and says [ __ ]
you to his daughter again my [ __ ] god
and it's indicative of why his mom was
sick in the first place too right what
about your insurance and she's like you
[ __ ] canceled the insurance spent all
the money and now i don't have insurance
yeah right that's part of his [ __ ]
character he's a [ __ ] gambler because
the theory of desire nothing is enough
yeah right for whatever carrot is
dangled in front of him he's got to
chase after it right it's such a weird
thing like when i look at him right
because i start to wonder too it's
even something small where uh he was
playing the uh the the arcade game to
get the gift yeah right yeah it's like
were you more happy that you won the
gamble or were you happy that you got
the gift for your daughter that's
exactly how it was presented too right
that how much
um it looked like the horse track scene
right the way he was gambling with the
horses he was gambling with that [ __ ]
ten bucks he had to take back from the
girl he did
you know
and spend it all on this game instead of
going out there and buying a ten dollar
[ __ ] gift yeah right because he has
to [ __ ] play this game like he's got
to
it's part of that gamble i i don't know
too much about what it's like to be a
gambling addict but
from what i've seen i'm assuming that's
pretty much all the p's and q's yeah
it's it's a thrill to chase right yeah
it's that's how it always feels like i
think that's kind of why i like crypto
i'm holding i'm holding yeah that's just
the blink
it's a thrill to chase with crypto i
think that's why i enjoy it too yeah and
you see like
i mean let's even talk about this this
is this is true to his character to
throughout the film this guy owes a
major amount of gambling debt to a bunch
of kangpes a bunch of gangsters right
so he has to make a blood pact because
if he doesn't pay this money back it's
the last time they're going to chase him
down he does it with the blood from his
nose because he socked him in the face
and puts the fingerprint down the guy
has absolutely zero shame before he
leaves he goes hold on yeah can i borrow
10 bucks
such a [ __ ]
wow it's like damn man just have some
[ __ ] dignity man
he has zero [ __ ] dignity you were
talking about this on the last one we
were when we were uh when we did the
shitty review of this movie where ever
how intricate the writing is right where
they were talking
you mentioned that everybody dies in the
way
um that they got into the game into the
game yeah that's just amazing foresight
right so uh we'll go down the list of
the characters first
uh kihun
he
wins the horse
race uh
thing uh what's it he wins four million
five hundred sixty thousand won
right and then he becomes four five six
in the games and he leaves with four
billion 560 million one
right that's crazy
um through all the mess that he's in
he's
he's soaking wet in a suit
trying to commit suicide in his bathroom
right the way he leaves the game he's
soaking wet in his suit and he commits
suicide
she goes to meet that north korean
broker who brings refugees into south
korea
she [ __ ] wounds the [ __ ] she
throws caught coffee in his face and
sticks a knife
in his neck
right
and threatens him
and to her demise she gets [ __ ]
stabbed in the neck
then uh ali
ali steals a stack of money from his
boss
right
and uh takes that money to his family
and then he goes play the game
well he gets his marbles stolen and he
gets offed
right
um who else did they follow is that
the gangpet
the gunper
[ __ ] um
turned on his boss he betrayed his boss
and he and then he betrayed some
filipinos yeah
so he made your gambling casino yeah and
they came aft so what does he he he
kills uh the gangster that was with him
his underling who started talking down
on him and then
welcome to korea yeah
gangsters
then he jumps off the bridge
you know to go into the games
then at the games he betrays menio right
the girl that crazy lady she's so good
yeah she's [ __ ] an amazing actor yeah
and
what does she do he betrays her even
though she threatened that i'll kill you
if you betray me
and she's like what did i say if you
betray me and they [ __ ] fall off a
bridge a bridge
that's just [ __ ] crazy dude this show
has amazing writing like you just gotta
watch it again and go ahead and read the
subtitles through and through you know
what's so funny too like every time i
watch these shows and i see these
gangplay-like characters right yeah have
you seen that guy's instagram
dude
he's a cat boy
he's like so soft
beautiful skinny
just like the soft face filter i'm like
what the [ __ ] is this guy dude dude
i had to look it up on his imd imdb
photo looks nothing like him a million
dollar smile yeah it's the kindest
looking soul i've ever seen in my life
and that's the funny thing too because
these guys are so good at portraying
characters i feel like sometimes when i
watch american films right
you'll i feel like all korean character
all korean actors who are really good
they're like all johnny depp's they
could transform into whatever the [ __ ]
you want them to transform into yeah
like you'll see this lady too i bet you
if you watch uh nino like if you see her
in an interview she's like how do i feel
yeah of course she is she's [ __ ]
sweet but she's like this hooker yeah
like a hooker in that whole show potty
mouth and she's such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
talker she's got that [ __ ] uh korean
female gangster vibe like
sophia chang
[Laughter]
sophia's not like that but yeah
but yeah like there are women like that
in korea too which is hilarious but um
yeah her character was such a solid
piece yeah like in the show and
dude let's talk about ali dude
his korean so [ __ ] good yeah and he
had to act like he was bad at korean i
know his koreans are hella that was you
know what that was the most shocking
[ __ ] thing so mario was super into
squid game as well right and it's very
rare that we actually like korean stuff
together yeah because typically she
likes stuff like um the north korean one
where the lady gets a tornado and she
gets blown into north korea she loves
[ __ ] like that
right my kami boyfriend which one is
that i forget i forget the title don't
forget the title it was like kissing you
forever
you know something like that
but she was oh she uh showed me a clip
of ali speaking korean right in an
interview it's korean it's
hella good yeah he's like an indian
immigrant
um
he wanted to be an actor for some reason
i guess he just didn't want to get into
bollywood but he wanted to get into
korean cinema and like got a scholarship
out here wow and i saw some of his
korean theater acting like he is like
damn damn damn good yeah
which kind of goes to show why all the
okay i do want to talk about this the
things that i really didn't like about
squid game is nothing to the fault of
the writing or anything
the american the english speaking oh my
gosh
the vip i wanted the [ __ ] i was like
how did you take me out of this series
they were like find me international
people in korea
so you could see so the vips weren't all
white there was like a japanese dude
there's a chinese dude right they were
just supposed to be rich people from
around the world yeah but you got to
think about it if you're a casting
director in korea like where the [ __ ] am
i going to find these english speaking
actors in korea i heard a um i was
reading a reddit post about it and
somebody who's who's living in korea
they say that a lot of these
english-speaking actors are just people
who are international like teachers who
teach english and then they just take up
acting to get on with some drama or
something yeah they'll pay them
something and just so they could be in a
film or a show and they all they speak
english so they bring him onto the show
something really quick because they're
not going to fly over yeah you know some
really well-known american actor bring
him over here pay all this other [ __ ]
just for the small part that really is
kind of insignificant that's what so
speaking of that tactic
when he reveals his face so that's the
front man right the man with the that
unique mask
what i don't think what western
audiences understand is as if you're
watching a regular tv show and all of a
sudden leonardo dicaprio
exactly
like that's that's that's actually a
really big [ __ ] face reveal as far as
like that's where they spend all that
acting money on dude i was actually
wondering how people who don't know who
he is how they were reading oh snake
eyes
that's what people would recognize him
from right now is that the snake guys
guys yeah and when mary and i were
watching it we went
yeah we went i was at home
[ __ ]
and then we all said the same me and
mary at the exact same time we said no
wonder his english is hella good yeah
dude
because english was perfect i'm like who
is this i read an article about
ibiyongkan talking about how he was
treated in america yeah he was treated
like [ __ ] on magnificent seven bro that
[ __ ] pissed me off
and you know i think it's
i think it's also very difficult for an
older korean man to talk about himself
in that type of vulnerable way yeah dude
like if he's he's
a big [ __ ] deal in korea like huge
yeah huge and he's one of the best [ __ ]
like we we were uh i saw the devil yeah
one of my two favorite actors on earth
dude uh the way he's supposed to be this
[ __ ] badass secret agent type like
dope at fighting all these like if i saw
the devil was an american movie who
could you cast because he has to cover
all those emotional scenes too right
while being dope at [ __ ] you know all
these action scenes
like how that he's so versatile
yeah
the hong kong actor yeah that speaks to
english yeah so like if you don't know
ibyankan like uh the front man like he's
a
that's a really big it's not even a
cameo like you know he's gonna have a
big part in the second season
yeah it was so big when he did that face
reveal i was i was so shocked and just
him talking about how people wouldn't
make eye contact with him they wouldn't
greet him they wouldn't yeah show him
any sign of respect but but the moment
this series blows up they go they start
reaching out to him they start talking
shaking his hand and it's just really
odd too because
and this is an ongoing theme that i say
with a lot of people you see this a lot
in major cities
people only
treat certain people with respect if
they can get something out of them yeah
and it's the most obnoxious thing i've
ever seen if you know people that you
could tell that they treat you
differently just based on who you are
you should already know that they're a
piece of [ __ ] yeah because it's terrible
like you'll i always see it when people
do it with um
servers
uh like how they treat servers yeah like
if they treat servers like a piece of
[ __ ] i'm guaranteeing you're a piece of
[ __ ] yeah because they always look at
other people as if they're tools and
tokens to get into where they want to be
and we've seen it time and time again so
and you kind of see it even on celebrity
status
like imagine if they even knew who he
was it's like do you know who this
[ __ ] guy is in korea like he is the
[ __ ] man like he is
the denzel washington
you know in south korea yeah but they
shouldn't have to know that to treat him
with some type of decency he's cast it
in this role they should be able to talk
to him he can speak perfect [ __ ]
english by the way yeah it's not a
language barrier thing his english is
[ __ ] perfect yeah
so that's and that's the
sad irony too like magnificent seven is
a remake of an older western that was a
remake of a samurai film yeah yeah yeah
and you're treating the asian guy on set
like [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] that's
right
then denzel was in it he was the main
guy right yeah yeah yeah
uh i think like chris pratt there was a
bunch of dudes in it it was like the
western expendables you know
when i read the article and he said that
at times like he felt like he was going
to cry i'm like
like for korean man to have to talk
about this [ __ ] be like they treated me
this way like i mean and you could see
it in the show the way the the men in
the show behave like
like if you talk [ __ ] to them they
[ __ ] want to stand their ground but
yeah imagine having to be powerless
like it's terrible that's that's [ __ ]
sad it [ __ ] sucks man yeah speaking
of uh
bad english
have you seen the show with english dubs
bro
i turned it on just to see there's two
things wrong with that i'm glad you
brought that up
hello my friends i'm excited to say this
this podcast is sponsored by
uncommon goods yes my friends if you
haven't heard of uncommon goods well
thank you you're welcome very much i'm
about to make your holiday shopping
super stress free this season guess what
who knows what holiday shoppings will
look like this season and the unique
gifts at uncommon goods can sell out
fast so you need to shop now and get it
taken care of super early uncommon goods
has a whole bunch of stuff that doesn't
have lackluster gifts we want lack full
gifts i'm not even sure that's a word
but that's how much i love uncommon
goods i get stressed out every holiday
because we got white elephant parties we
have a bunch of people that we need to
buy small gifts for and you don't want
to give wack gifts you got to go to
uncommon goods and by the way with every
purchase you make in uncommon goods they
also give back a dollar to a non-profit
partner of your choice this isn't crap
stuff this is meaningful stuff dope
stuff out of the ordinary gifts that you
can get there so to get 15 percent off
your next gift go to uncommongoods.com
brain that's uncommongoods.com brain for
15 percent off don't miss out on this
limited time offer uncommon goods
we're all out of the ordinary the
english even beyond the dubs the
translations were terrible yeah the
translations
mary all night were getting a little
irritated because
who the [ __ ] translated this [ __ ] well
it's because they have to try to match
the words with the way their mouth is
moving but it's like you're never gonna
get it well you never look at the mouth
and read the words yeah
so just
[ __ ] make it what it's supposed to be
i can't think of specific examples but i
just remember because marielle's just is
just listening to the korean yeah there
are some some korean words i don't
understand so i have to every now and
then i'll have to look at the
translation and i stopped when we were
watching it i'm like that's not what he
said
why the [ __ ] did they what is this [ __ ]
well oh you're talking about the
subtitles the subtitles right the
subtitles i was talking about the dubbed
acting when they get american actors
on top of that do the subtitles with the
dubbed yeah okay
yeah they're
different like none of the patches like
they don't the way the korean actors are
emoting their face and then the way the
voices are coming out don't match either
right dude so it takes me out hey
the ill nom actor
why is he mr miyagi how come he has this
accent
he'll give me marble
when you pray the tug of war
what okay can i just tell you this
though by the way it's [ __ ] master
splinter anyway
when i when i was first auditioning and
acting right i i kind of drew a line
with this [ __ ] um i started doing
auditions for voice over acting for
games and the thing that irritated me
the most was when i had to um audition
for japanese characters and i had to be
samurai warriors in a lot of these like
famous games right yeah and i just at a
certain point i just couldn't do it
anymore because it's like okay you're
gonna be it's gonna have an accent but a
slight accent but not too much what the
[ __ ] does that mean i don't know what
game you're talking about
and so i would do
this japanese samurai
and i'm sitting here doing this audition
in front of them right yeah and i have
to do this and because they're going to
put like a mocap on you and [ __ ] you're
supposed to do all the motions and the
movements it's for like these larger
japanese men or whatever what not i
think they're sumo wrestlers to be
honest with you
you know they didn't want to outright
stand but i think why are these dots
going down my stomach and why is my hair
tied back in the bun
did you say i was supposed to be a
samurai warrior like no you're a sumo
it's like i need another soup and a bowl
of water
i need to take my nap no but they're
literally asking me to do actions like
that and when i saw the the dub version
of his voice i was like that would be
the world that i'd be auditioning for uh
that [ __ ] accent when really it
should have just been a korean accent or
maybe no accident at all well well shout
out to the english cast at least they
are asian
but it's like that one guy he had to do
it with the accent for the old man i
wouldn't that'd be so [ __ ] funny if
it's like a white dude oh
i like to do the actually gotta look
that
up good i'd be cracking the [ __ ] up i
wouldn't be offended i think this is
hilarious but the the idiom voice actor
was the [ __ ]
worst yeah
it was
pretty bad all around like um especially
migno
her character too because she always has
those monologues where she's just
talking [ __ ] forever
right and then i was curious let me see
that in english and it just wasn't the
same
you know then i watched it in french
it worked oh it worked yeah then i saw
it in spanish it worked then i realized
oh those languages actually emote like
with their voice the way you know like
even italian you see the way talents
talk
it comes out the way they're they're
talking about their hands and their face
it's weird because
i think sometimes when they do the
translations they do it directly and it
doesn't
because there's so much like vocal
inflections in korean it becomes hyper
expressive right so if you say something
like this right
yeah right and if you translate directly
where are you who are you
is that what it is
yeah who are you yeah
like
it's more like the [ __ ] are you you know
so if somebody says that to you if you
see that in those korean dramas and
somebody comes up out of nowhere and
they speak out of turn they go
it's like yo who the [ __ ] are you yeah
how do you translate oh my
oh
you know koreans crying
how do you translate that into english
right exactly and you know even a lot of
like korean words even curse words are
hyper expressive oh my gosh that's
another part right
for every [ __ ] you see in the subtitles
trust me there's a different word for it
yeah
they just put [ __ ] in there yeah so you
realize like wow we're like the korean
language has so many different curse
words and there's just really good
accuracy
like a simple phrase too it doesn't
actually mean [ __ ] off if somebody says
to you like godzilla that means like
turn off yeah turn off yeah
hey turn off but if you wanted to
translate it it would be an equivalent
to [ __ ] off or [ __ ] you get out of here
you know what i mean yeah so there's
just a lot of stuff too that's why we go
back to how would this be translated
into or
i don't think it's a good idea to take
squid game and then redo it with an
american cast it would be good to do
squid game where they go into a
different country
yeah and then have an american cast
play their version of squid game
whatever the [ __ ] it is it may not be as
good but it would be better than
trying to remake it with american actors
with the same type of scenario because
it just doesn't make sense yeah season
two like could be a squid game i mean
they'd probably call it something else
like in different countries wherever
kids play tic-tac-toe yeah
the tic-tac-toe yeah
wall balls
so i have a friend who's an elementary
school teacher and they're having a
an issue right now because these
elementary school kids are playing are
playing red light green light but
they're doing it with the shooter and
they're killing each other off
[Laughter]
which i'm trying to figure out who the
[ __ ] are these kids parents yeah why are
these kids watching squid games i don't
know
but they're playing red light green
light yeah and then there's somebody you
know doing the red light and holding a
tree and they'll turn around and choose
people who they can kill and shoot off
and they'll go pop and they all have to
die and fall on the floor
wow they [ __ ] changed it yeah
why can't it just be regular red light
green light hey that's a huge cultural
impact it's like i learned it from the
koreans yeah it's like
[ __ ] hell but so many people have
watched this and so many people even
beyond parasite they're like oh i think
korean people got some really good [ __ ]
yeah or they think we're really [ __ ]
twisted that's a beauty of twisted yeah
well that's the beauty of like when
korean cinema like parasite and squid
game get big they want to go back and
look at all the other films that they
missed out on and then they come across
[ __ ] old boy yeah
and they come across like i saw the
devil or whatever but yeah there's so
much good content coming we still have
to do a review of i saw the devil
because i actually lost that footage
yeah i was so drunk and high i was
crossfaded so bad during that recording
i was drinking there's times dude i just
recorded another one yesterday where i
have to turn on mic again i got to stop
drinking before yeah
before i do the podcast because
sometimes too this is just fun
conversation i forget that we're
recording [ __ ] yeah and so i have to do
like a double triple check on it yeah i
see you always kind of making sure wait
i am recording right yeah because i keep
doing that [ __ ] over and over again but
we'll we'll do i saw the devil because
obviously ibiyan hyun he's one of the
main characters in that film with my
favorite actor of all time
literally my favorite actor ever there's
not a single actor that comes above
championship hands down i don't give a
[ __ ] what anybody says that's true if i
wanted to be an actor i want to follow
in his footsteps because every role that
he does he [ __ ]
kills it kills it yeah i've heard this
he's like a big time buddhist too so
like after he ate that octopus he like
had to pray for a few hours oh my god i
didn't know that yeah
but i mean that's i mean he's such an
amazing actor the way he is the way he
[ __ ] can
like hold on so many different types of
characters and like
different moods too i think people will
understand too when when i the reason
why i like korean films or a lot of my
sensibility comes from a lot of these
korean films no matter how serious
something is there's always stupid funny
[ __ ] jokes all the time yeah they
they
go off of classic films where um
i mean you look at comedies today and
like look like like ghostbusters have
you seen the new ghostbusters remake
it's
non-stop talking jokes but it's the kind
of jokes where they just keep
talking and talking and talking and
talking and it's random it seems like
it's
um
improv yeah on camera they just let it
roll and then they take the best takes
whatever but in so many of like the
korean drama
and like thrillers or whatever for some
moment there's just like
there's no dialogue but there's just
something hilarious that they put on
screen that it ties to the character but
it's just like it lines the mood without
having to have a weird like stick to it
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just so good a
lot of just i think just that's how
korean people are yeah they make jokes
out of misery 24 [ __ ] seven and just
very hyper exaggerated human beings like
the way that we threaten people the way
that we talk to people the way that we
give compliments
everything is so extreme and super
exaggerated that's why i like my sassy
girl like you see when we talked about
that how funny were all these like their
imagination comes to life like on screen
and that's the beauty of of that movie
it's like it's it's pretty meta for
filmmaking you can tell the guy who
wrote the movie is a huge movie buff
he's a movie fan like the crazy thing
was what what was that film written like
2008
oh i think it was earlier than that
that's nuts yeah and nobody would give
it a chance right they thought it was
either it just wouldn't sell it wouldn't
make sense or something else which which
is very interesting too because
there's a lot of stuff too when when you
kind of create there's a time and place
for it i think it's cut it's hard right
because i've tried to sell and pitch
ideas all the [ __ ] time but the way
that i want to do it people just don't
believe in it they don't think that
people are ready for it but speaking of
that though this show in particular
squid game right
the [ __ ] writer director wrote it in
2008 yeah and he was saying the same
thing it wouldn't have sold at that time
yeah yeah right it had to be like at
this time now parasite had to come out
everything else yeah well that makes
sense too then right because i mean it
reminds me of the story of sylvester
stallone when he had rocky so when he
wrote rocky he was [ __ ] homeless
he was homeless as [ __ ] and then he had
he sold his dog right i've read that
that that story yeah yeah he sold his
dog and he was living out of his car and
it was you know [ __ ] cold as [ __ ] and
then uh somebody was trying to sell like
buy the script offer for like ten
thousand dollars or something and he
goes nah i'm gonna shoot it i'm gonna
i'm gonna do everything with it and he
had to hold on to it and eventually when
he got the money he found his dog and he
and he bought his dog back yeah which is
crazy how much these people believe in
their projects so much that they'll hold
on to it let me tell you if i'm living
out of a car someone's like ten thousand
don't take it
i'll write it i'll write another one so
i'll figure it out you've got to be a
hardcore believer yeah
i mean to say but the the writer of this
i'm sad i didn't write his name on my
notes but um he was living in a mana
checkpoint you know manachekbang is
basically a comic book store and in
korea like it's a huge library of just
like manga or manoa and it's 24 7. yeah
24 7 but then like these vagrants just
go in there and pay for their time to
read but they're really just jacking off
just sleeping there
yeah
just living there yeah so it's amazing
he wrote this story when he was living
in a manager
so he was in the gutter when he wrote it
which makes sense as when you
you you see how the story plays out and
as if he was a player in the game too
right like
where he's got nothing and he's in a
huge amount of debt
and you can see that
like if you broke this uh down to its
script
you can see it as a manga you could see
it as a monument yeah yeah yeah like
every frame
every like shot is like [ __ ] perfect
and even the visual cues of when he like
kihun's yelling at whoever's out there
watching like this man killed this guy
is this how we're supposed to play the
game and then it cuts to the front man
like he is listening yeah yeah yeah yeah
like i can only imagine the storyboards
are dope i want to see this as a manager
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what was so
sad too and it was
it's that guy who was paired up with his
wife yeah his wife was in there and he
had to kill his wife and then
you see him kind of go into this peril
he starts spinning out of control he
goes let's all just vote let's get out
of here what are we even doing here and
then lo and behold who comes in and
starts lecturing him yeah he goes
uh what's that not cute
sango comes in and starts lecturing him
he goes
if you wanted to leave this game so much
why did you kill your wife you should
have killed yourself
[Music]
what the [ __ ] bro that's the argument of
the theory of desire right what did he
really want did he want this money
or his wife right and he gave up his
[ __ ] wife and then regretted it so
when that scene came out marielle of
course looks at me and she just goes she
goes would you have killed me
of course this woman like she's she
would have to make it about herself and
i look at her and i say no i'd kill
myself a hundred percent yeah and she
goes would you i was like yeah because i
can't live with the guilt knowing that i
killed you and then she looks at me
which i thought was a very sweet line
she goes so you're selfish
she goes so you're only not killing me
not because you love me because you
can't live with the guilt
[Laughter]
so what if i can live with the guilt
but
you know i'll kill you i'll kill you and
i can also live with that too
how did you turn this on me dude it's
like but if if i die then how are you
going to win the game by yourself
you're not going to get the money either
i have a chance yeah
i'll [ __ ] build a memorial for you
don't worry about it oh man oh dude that
part two where
uh he pushed the uh the glass maker oh
he had one last and you know at the end
of the day too
he had to do what he had to do because
he was taking forever and that was a
pivotal moment
because before
he was playing hella sharky behind the
lines behind the scenes he didn't want
people to know that's how he was playing
the game because with the the [ __ ] um
the sugar thing
or the uh
yeah
he didn't tell his teammates his plan
right that's right playing sharky as
[ __ ] which goes to show this is how he
plays a game of life
the reason why he's he was such a big
wig out in the real world
was because that's how he does business
yeah and then that's also the reason why
he got into the game because it made him
lose
high stakes i remember when i watched it
again i don't even know why i glanced
over this part but it was when he
figured out what the game was and he
chose not to say anything at all and he
just had a little bit of hey do you are
you sure you want to play that [ __ ] are
you sure you want to play it that [ __ ]
crack you know what i was kind of
cracking up too was you sent me that
[ __ ] meme where it was the was it you
yeah it was the pokey and then it was
like a quote
that became a huge huge obsession too
yeah dude everybody's making it on uh
instagram reels and tick tock dude
nongshim was doing it too i'm like you
make ramyun yeah what the hell are you
doing
the funny thing is people don't know
that candy's whack
what is it sugar and baking soda yeah
that's all that is burnt sugar and
baking soda and people are like well
this is so cool and you know i watched
videos and like this is so good
nobody thinks it tastes good in korea
it's like like poor kids it's poor
people can yeah like novelty
you know who liked it my dead
grandmother yeah for sure but that's
that was the whole idea right that
the part of the games was that older
people had an advantage because they
knew the games right yeah the young kids
didn't know what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] was
yeah right i only know what it tastes
like because when i was in korea there's
this old in town that you go to it's
like medieval times you know those uh
right and then they have to be in
character
and they'll make they'll they're
actually making like
from like way back in the way like
korean blood sausage they're making all
these old can they have like dried uh
preserved persimmons and they had the
porky candy and you see them making it
and i remember i ate it in korea i'm
like this is black
no one's everybody don't eat it anymore
i was like she's so
basic and black yeah it's it's funny
when people get enraptured by a culture
and they talk to you about something
that's a part of yours that you don't
even know that i don't like yeah
i dislike it and they go dude i had
freaking your dal gonna candies how
[ __ ] amazing is it and i'm looking at
them
this [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks what are you
talking about like yeah it doesn't taste
good it's just there it's old people
candy what the [ __ ] are you saying yeah
and that's part of the hype behind it
right like
you know
it's it's it's it's also with uh
chapaguri a website right everyone
started
why were we we eating chapaguri to have
a decent big ass salty meal yeah like
because we're broke what do they call it
in parasite i don't i don't remember
yeah i have no idea
i was like i remember when they did that
right they're like oh make me land i'm
like the [ __ ] is that that's chappa
goody dude yeah dude
and they're calling kakao kakaotak
whatsapp like why
why that's pretty aggrieved it's like
what the [ __ ] you're you're literally
taking the promo out of what yeah what
kakao talk means in korea right like
there was a huge facebook crash this
past week right it was all over that's
right took down instagram facebook and
whatsapp right and then people
understood oh my gosh people rely on
communication through whatsapp it's like
do you have any idea how much korea
relies on kakao talk yeah a whole bunch
yeah my uncle got mad at me because i
stopped responding to him in cacao yeah
but i just deleted the app me too so
same deal yeah i don't really want to
talk to anybody on it this little
[ __ ] at thanksgiving comes up to me
he goes you chew hollywood to respond
back to your uncle i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about he goes i've
been messaging you all cacao [ __ ]
every other week and you don't message
me and i'm like i haven't had that
happen two years nobody uses it here and
first of all you first of all i if
you're listening to this [ __ ] stop
sending me bible verses
stop that [ __ ]
so obnoxious
it's so [ __ ] annoying and then he
always sends me a bible verse and then
it's like a gift of jesus christ
i hope you're protecting your virginity
david
i gave that up years ago
you idiot they [ __ ] hate you so much
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast it is the
long-awaited breakdown
of squid game i'm pretty sure there's a
lot more other stuff that we could have
talked about all the clues to why ilnam
was always in control oh let's see okay
okay we're not and then yeah okay yeah
okay let's talk about this now yeah
we forgot to mention too that in the
game all the games are on the walls
right right so when you see that when
it's down to three all the bunks are
taken out
enough
people were trying to figure out what
the games were and it was just it was
just there the whole time the biggest
thing too that when uh when i remember
when i watched it again
um
i didn't realize how much in control he
was because when everybody started
killing each other when did the game
stop
when he said everybody it's like double
i was scared musa
and then it stopped yeah he's the reason
why the killing stopped because he got
freaked out yeah yeah and like uh
he
he opts out right when they do that big
vote
to leave i think it was the first
episode right that's right right
and he votes no
and then at the last episode when he
comes back
um like
big shock big twist
and
you see his whole thing like and this is
the big thing what differentiates this
show
from all the other ones like battle
royale and that all that other [ __ ] is
that this is completely voluntary you
chose to play the game and i gave you
every chance to quit and you guys kept
playing the game that's the idea and i
think that's the allegory to our society
today about capitalism right you gotta
choose to play the game yeah he they
literally proved his [ __ ] point yeah
you know he goes i give you an out i've
even showed you half the people getting
murdered and shot to death and you still
decide to [ __ ] come back yeah so why
are you mad at me right yeah what did i
do you chose to [ __ ] be here also too
he's number one
in in the game
speaking of that so the cop
he finds all those records right um very
important things that the front man
played the game in 2015
and won right because he turns out to be
the cops brother right who was missing
the whole time
um the game started in 1988 or whatever
these games
happen in 2020
right that's the 20 24 that he goes
through he opens a 2020 folder and
what's the first page player002
oh
he took his own record out
that's right yeah
and then um you go through i mean i i
heard ones that were [ __ ] like i
looked it up like they said he wasn't
actually chained to the rope he was okay
yeah i think like he says about the
whole idea of it being chemiseof oh you
know what i saw it the second time i'm
not sure people uh mentioned this like
in a theory but one of the things that i
picked up that kind of made me a little
excited was when he was talking about um
the milk thing and he goes oh i had a
son that did it like that i was like is
that [ __ ] your dad yeah so i've
seen a lot of those too so people have
talked about that yes that [ __ ] i when i
when i heard it again i'm like
huh
are they dropping a hint here but my
friend gave another theory
that the front man ebyeon hyun is
actually his son
that one made more sense to me oh yeah
yeah yeah like yes there's a connection
between the three of them you don't know
i'm the old man
are our main protagonist
and the front mandy beyond right
that there are all the similar similar
type of character archetypes right to be
in the position they're in but also the
idea of
how nothing is enough
right i mean in the front man's
apartment when it was being investigated
he was reading that book the theory of
desire why at that point he had won the
games he has millions of dollars right
but he was living in a shitty [ __ ]
studio apartment
right with shared bathrooms and all that
[ __ ] right yeah he was living in squalor
he wasn't doesn't seem like he was using
any of that money yeah what does he
really want what does he desire what is
not enough for him that he has to keep
filling this hole for himself the whole
reason why illinois started these games
because nothing
everything was boring life was boring
nothing was enough
you know
and for you in the same way where um
nothing is that is enough for him yeah
right
those are the archetypes i follow about
these three
why ilnam was drawn towards kihun and
why they were partnered up so many times
right and he was saying it was fun
playing with you i like playing with you
i think in the past
like this could be season two theories
right that maybe in the 2015 games he
also played and he played with ebyongyun
right and he probably pulled the same
[ __ ] off or whatever
but at the same time the theory about
the front man being his son because he
does take over the games right
at the end of the day i really don't
think it matters if they're their son or
not but that he was still looking for
successors yeah yeah yeah
i think either way it could be kyun or
it could be the front man to be his kids
like here like
he was saying
um
that
kyung helped him remember right when
they were playing the marbles game
because they set up that neighborhood
[Music]
the one he grew up in
how would gilgame know that that
like what where is nam grew up yeah but
i think the front man would know
where they grew up
right because this is the house where he
worked his ass off to take care of his
kids but these kids wouldn't recognize
him whenever he came home because they
were too
enthralled in their game
and he wanted to feel that way where you
lose track of time and everything else
all the [ __ ] that's happening in the
world
because this is the funnest thing
happening right now damn yeah that's
crazy
yeah i don't even think about it like
that
it's just so many good clues there's so
many like hidden little things in there
like you could watch it again and again
i mean that was this thing too when i
watched it the second time around and
it's funny too i i read a couple of
comments from people like why would you
walk watch it again two times over i'm
like
because there's so much to it yeah like
you
if you didn't watch it two times over
and you really enjoyed this that means
you only got the surface level of
watching people die yeah
that's the only reason why you like that
shock and awe yeah that's
this the reason why squid game is so
good is beyond that shocking all cause
we've heard it multiple times before
this this format technically has been
done multiple times
the the writer took his
uh he took the influence from you know
stuff like battle royale and all these
other shows that's not why this show is
great yeah right and you don't really
have to even dig that deep so if you're
looking at this you go oh this is battle
royale over again you're missing the
whole point of squid game you didn't
watch this watch it again one more time
because during that scene when he
finally got what he wanted he was
fulfilled he opted to go out he didn't
give him the marble to teach him this
great lesson yeah he was done yeah he
was [ __ ] done it took the magic away
from this emotional scene when i watched
it again twice it was oh
i got what i needed from you
here's the marble continue this game
without me because i'm done he has no
point in being in this game anymore yeah
so it kind of flipped the whole meaning
of it that that he was having fun it was
great it's like everything's going to be
all right
[Laughter]
enjoy yeah and that's that's the the
difference too like uh if you watch
um all these other death game genre
movies um
it's a horror right it's presented more
like a horror
it's it's very cynical so
a lot of them get creative in the ways
people die they entertain you through
death
right but
all the deaths in squid games were
tragic
they weren't good they weren't funny
when people died yeah they were
shockingly horrible that was the horror
yes nobody's head was getting sliced
multiple different ways there wasn't
some impossible game that was going to
[ __ ] you up like
yeah you know it wasn't like destination
yeah it wasn't like that at all it was
very much more like an allegory to our
society like even though the three rules
to the the contract that they had
assigned it was like an employment paper
yeah you want to work here this is what
you got to do you can't stop playing the
game
unless everybody decides that they want
to leave
and then oh [ __ ] what was the second
rule
i forget but like um
third world like i guess it could be
equated to going on strike or something
everyone getting a fair chance that was
the most important thing about the games
that they had right yeah
yeah the uh the other thing about
illinois oh man it just escaped my head
[ __ ]
because we'll have to bring it up
in another episode or something yeah
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the jesus break podcast for real this
time you can just keep on finding these
little gems and easter eggs if there's
other stuff that you guys saw that you
want to mention right in the comments
talk about it because i want to read all
that [ __ ] i did i didn't read too much
of the the theories because i wanted to
read it later after the podcast because
i just wanted to talk about the stuff
that i saw just watching it over again
but there's probably so many other
things i'm missing but if you haven't
seen squid game yet we probably just
ruined it for you well if you didn't
watch it you're you and i don't know
there's a billion people who have so
you're missing out yeah one of the best
[ __ ] series you'll ever see and it's
on [ __ ] netflix amazing amazing it's
part of what they invested like half a
billion dollars into korean content
that's amazing this is all worth it all
worth it just for one show dude yeah all
worth it they had it they had to get it
knocking out the park somehow uh you
could catch ed at ed parkvp
on instagram
are you still doing your podcast uh i
have a few ideas written out but i've
been so [ __ ] lazy about it that's why
i haven't been mentioning it okay when i
do i will bring it up again okay okay
and then genius praying every thursday
sundays up until january 1st january 1st
we're going once a week but until then
we'll see you all next time peace